[Music]
life on board a spaceship is so busy
people just don't know the Mission
Control schedules your time there's this
this line moving across your computer
screen that shows what you're doing
every five minutes for your entire six
months on a spaceship so it is dictated
and controlled environment up there and
nowhere does it ever say go look out the
window but you just can't help yourself
every time you get ahead of that line if
you give yourself an extra three or four
minutes you float through the station on
the handrails you pull yourself down
into the cupola window and and you take
another look at the world and it is so
many things all at once it's beautiful
it's just raw constantly changing beauty
pouring by around you it's instructional
you'll learn so much about the world you
see how everything actually fits
together and the history of it and the
and the geology and the geography of it
but it's also a feeling of great
privilege of like awe of like you've
just walked into the most magnificent
art gallery on earth or or into the
Sistine Chapel or into a rainforest or
somewhere where suddenly you're just
overwhelmed with the place that you are
it's it's an amazing stolen moment and I
stole as many of those as I could as
astronauts we train more than anybody
knows I had photographers train me house
oblige cameras was 70 millimeter film
and Arriflex cameras and I became an
IMAX cameraman and helped make two IMAX
movies and Lynn Hoff cameras and and the
whole gamut of complex photography with
all of those photographers talking about
not just portraiture and not just the
inside but how to take a good picture of
the world and what parts of the world we
haven't seen yet and you know some
places have a lot of cloud cover and
maybe one day you'll get a great picture
of the Panama Canal or a part of the
Amazon that's never been photographed
because it's always so cloudy and so you
are hyper prepared to be one of the
world's four
AFER's up there you're really trying to
make sure that you're technically
competent with the camera but you're
also artistically capable of
understanding how to compose a picture
how to frame it properly how to
recognize something that's worth taking
a picture of and and you don't always
get it right
I mean the National Geographic
photographers they take thousands of
pictures from everyone that makes it
into the magazine same for us but the
world is a very generous photography
subject and you have the best tripod in
existence so it's a great place to take
pictures I was lucky enough to fly in
space three times flew the space shuttle
twice there I was the pilot of the
Russian Soyuz on my third flight I
helped build two space stations I've
done a couple spacewalks and throughout
all of those hundred and sixty-six days
in space 2,600 times around the world
every chance I could I would try and get
to the window and take a picture because
who wouldn't I mean it's just too
beautiful and rare a sight to ignore and
so when you total all up after all of
those space flights including while I
was outside on spacewalks I think I took
about 45 thousand pictures and a lot of
them are terrible you know just things
going by or the glare of the atmosphere
out of focus or you know you're just
you're just trying to make sure that
somewhere in there the pictures are good
and what do you do with 45,000 pictures
you no one's gonna sit down and look at
them all so a couple years after I
returned from my third spaceflight I
went through all 45,000 and as I went
through the 45,000 I would flag oh yeah
that's a good picture that's a good
picture that's but so I ended up with
sort of a nice smaller subset of
worthwhile pictures that should be
looked at and then I I thought if
someone was floating next to me at the
window of the spaceship what would I
want to show them you know if we were
going around the world once what where
would I want to go Hey look at that
this look wait till you see this wait do
you see the the great eye of the desert
on the edge of the Sahara or you know
wait till you see the Skeleton Coast for
though the
between the United States in Mexico or
all of the interesting parts of the
world that are different than you expect
to see and I went through all those
pictures the best pictures that I taken
and chose a hundred and fifty I thought
that really showed the story of the
world and those are my my absolute best
trying to distill this whole planet down
150 pictures is crazy it's an insult to
the world but it was the best I could do
to to let people actually see what the
world looks like I called it you are
here around the world in 92 minutes but
my whole thought at the time was if I
had a good friend sitting next to me
what parts of the world should they see
[Music]